bonjour avant de commencer ce nouvel
épisode de gentes dames badass je tiens
à vous signaler que la femme dont je
vais vous parler n'a pas été choisie au
hasard
elle fait partie des nombreuses femmes
citées dans le jeu de société féministe
bat is only dont je vous parlerai
plus amplement en fin d'épisode
et oui ceci est un placement de produit
rosaline franklyn et responsable
d'avancées majeures dans les domaines de
la chimie du charbon de la structure des
virus et de la structure de l'adn
elle est à l'origine de la découverte de
la structure en double hélice de l'adn
qui aurait pu lui valoir un prix nobel
et une reconnaissance mondiale
mais les choses se sont passées un peu
différemment mais on va voir pourquoi
francklin est né en 1920 à londres dans
une famille juive bourgeoise et le
milieu dans lequel elle grandit est
attachée aux traditions
les filles sont instruites mais sont
destinés à se marier et à participer à
des oeuvres de charité
certainement pas à travailler ses
parents semblent cependant montré peu de
résistance à son envie d'étudier les
sciences
elle montre très tôt des prédispositions
en mathématiques est inscrite à la saint
paul goerg school l'une des seules
écoles de londres qui enseigne la
physique et la chimie aux jeunes filles
elle apprend aussi le latin et le
français et obtient une bourse
universitaire en 1938 elle entre donc
dans l'un des collèges de cambridge mais
pas n'importe comment à l'époque temps
oblige ne compte que 10 % de femmes qui
ne sont que tolérée elles peuvent suivre
les cours mais seulement rassemblé entre
femmes au premier rang elles peuvent
passer leurs examens mais n'obtiennent
pas de diplôme elles ne sont même pas
appeler miss mes soeurs comme les hommes
francklin poursuit ses études sans se
révolter contre cela
sa seule volonté est d'apprendre
toujours à prendre pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale elle travaille sur le
carbone qui peut permettre de créer des
masques à gaz et des carburants sa
famille recueil de jeunes réfugiés juifs
fuyant l'europe continentale et franklyn
et garde dans l'air red pros kochanski
et assurent la surveillance et la
sécurité pendant les bombardements
le tout en rédigeant sa thèse sur la
porosité du charbon qu'elle soutient
avec succès en 1945 après l'obtention de
son doctorat elle entre au laboratoire
central des services chimiques de paris
pour se former à la cristallographie aux
rayons x
il s'agit d'une technique élaboré au
début du 20e siècle consistant à
bombarder un échantillon avec des rayons
x pour en tirer une image la
cristallographie était d'abord utilisé
sur des minéraux comme le carbone sur
lequel elle travaille avant d'être
employé sur les hormones les protéines
et autres molécules biologiques
en france elle est bien marie curie est
passée par là et ça se sent au niveau
des institutions
francklin est bien plus proche des
scientifiques france
avec elle peut avoir des discussions
animées que des anglais un peu trop
feutré et un peu trop sexiste
pourtant elle retourne en angleterre en
1951 elle est recrutée par le king's
college de londres pourrait étudié l'adn
par cristallographie elle passe sous la
direction de john rendall ea pour
collègue maurice wilkins wilkins et elle
travaille en parallèle sur les mêmes
recherches la situation se tend
rapidement d'autant que les premiers
résultats de franklyn réfute les
théories de wilkins l'adn est découvert
en 1871 mais on ne connaît pas encore
son utilité ni sa structure on pense
alors que ce sont les protéines aussi
présente dans les chromosomes qui sont à
l'origine des caractères héréditaires
franklyn parvient à distinguer les
formes a et b de l'adn et surtout elle
réalise le cliché 51 qui permet
d'identifier la structure en double
hélice de l'adn
c'est une découverte majeure mais
franklyn ne s'empresse pas de publier à
ce sujet elle est perfectionniste et
recherchent le meilleur cliché les
meilleurs résultats avant de proposer un
modèle sans réaliser que ses collègues
sont tous en pleine course à l'adn elle
n'est pas du tout carriériste
contrairement à wilkins et à deux autres
chercheurs de cambridge watson et crick
dont on reparlera très bientôt
en attendant l'ambiance reste mauvaise à
king's collège certains professeurs
refusent que les femmes mangent dans la
même préfecture que les hommes la
plupart des clubs qui permette vie
sociale et réseautage sont non mixtes
wilkins la considère comme une
assistante ou l'ignorent à cause de cela
elle quitte king's college en 1953 et
doit laisser ses travaux sur l'adn
elle rejoint le bareback collège où
elles appliquent ces travaux de
cristallographie sur les virus il permet
la découverte de la structure du virus
de la mosaïque du tabac quelques mois
après avoir quitté king's collège son
ancien supérieur l'appelle pour lui
ordonné d'arrêter de travailler sur
l'adn juste après comme par hasard un
article de watson et crick paraît dans
la revue nature
décrivant la structure en double hélice
de l'adn évidemment n'est pas citée il
se trouve que wilkinson ancien collègue
de francs qu'il avait montré ses
résultats et ses clichés à watson et
crick après son départ de king's college
watson et crick n'ont jamais fait une
expérience de cristallographie ils
prétendent avoir établi un modèle de
l'adn que le cliché 51 est venue
confirmer sans citer les travaux de rosa
d'une franchise alors que ce sont ses
résultats et son cliché qui ont créé le
modèle wilkins écrit à ce propos de
chercheurs vous êtes de belles
fripouille mais je crois que vous avez
trouvé la clé francklin ne se défend
même pas puisque l ignorent que watson
et crick ont vu ses travaux dans son
livre la doubler
disparu en 1968 watson ne dissimule pas
vraiment ce qu'il pense de franklyn
j'étais plus au courant de ces travaux
qu'elle ne l'imaginait
plusieurs mois plus tôt wilkinson avait
résumé la nature de ces prétendus
résultats anti hélico et de francis
meilhan assuré que c'était travaux à
cinq pattes j'ai décidé de risquer
l'explosion sans hésiter davantage je
répliquais qu'elle n'était pas
compétente pour interpréter ces clichés
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas que sur ses
compétences qu'ils trouvent quelque
chose à redire
malgré un visage volontaire n était
pourtant pas dépourvue de charme et
aurait même pu être séduisante si elle
s'était ne fût ce qu'un tantinet
préoccuper de son habillement mais cela
ne l'intéressé pas pas la moindre trace
de roubles sur ses lèvres pour
contraster avec ses cheveux noirs bien
tiré à 31 ans à le déployer en matière
de robes l'imagination ingrate d'un
jeune vab le britannique
il persiste aussi à l'appeler rosie pain
surnom qu'elle déteste et raison pour
laquelle j'ai décidé de naples et que
par son nom dans cet épisode comme pour
les scientifiques masculin en 1962
wilkins watson et crick reçoivent le
prix nobel pour la découverte de la
structure à double hélice de l'adn
francklin n'est cité que par wilkins
dans les discours de remerciement et ne
peut de toute façon pas se défendre non
plus en 1956 on les détecte un cancer
des ovaires probablement dues à son
exposition aux rayons x
elle subit une interdiction de
travailler mais c'est hors de question
pour elle elle met ses affaires en ordre
dresse un compte rendu de ces travaux
continuent jusqu'au bout et meurt le 16
avril 1958 elle avait 37 ans
de nombreux scientifiques surtout des
femmes meurent de cancer ou de leucémie
au cours du 20e siècle principalement à
cause de la méconnaissance des dangers
les rayons x
la mort prématurée tragique de rosalind
est une grande perte pour la science à
l'aide des techniques expérimentales et
mathématiques danalyse aux rayons x les
plus ingénieuses elle confirma et
clarifia l'hypothèse lumineuse de watson
et crick de la structure en double
hélice de cette substance
elle apportait la preuve irréfutable que
la principale chaîne de sucre et de
phosphate de l'acide nucléique est situé
à l'extérieur et non à l'intérieur de
l'hélice ce qu'elle avait suggéré avec
certitude
rosaline franklyn est donc l'une des
nombreuses femmes dont les découvertes
ont été oubliés et faceo prise de haut
par leurs collègues masculins
elle souffre de l'effet mathilde a
théorisé par margaret rose sitter dans
les années 80 qui veut que les femmes de
bénéficient que très peu des retombées
de l'ordre
verte dans les années 70 grâce à la
montée du féminisme angleterre rosalie
franklyn devient une icône dans son pays
on cherche à lui redonner sa place dans
l'histoire des sciences l'article
qu'elle allait publier paraît finalement
en 1968 et une biographie de sa vie sort
en 1974 elle devient une figure
féministe
grâce à son indépendance c'est à cause
de la manière dont elle a été traitée
par ses collègues
bien qu'on ne connaisse pas vraiment
c'est mon opinion social ou politique
francklin n'était peut-être pas
féministe mais elle a plus que souffert
du sexisme de son milieu et de la
société depuis que son nom est sorti de
l'oubli
de nombreux hommages lui ont été rendus
l'école dans laquelle elle avait étudié
la reconnaît comme l'une de ses élèves
les plus illustres
le ressort de nombreux prix à titre
posthume et le futur rover martien de l'
agence spatiale européenne sera baptisée
en son honneur
ce sera la première fois qu'un engin
l'exploration spatiale portera le nom
d'une femme scientifique et quarante ans
après sa mort watson et crick
reconnaisse enfin qu'il n'aurait jamais
établi leur modèle ni obtenu le prix
nobel sont les travaux de rosalind
franklin
tu affirmes fréquemment et semble
insinuer dans sa dernière lettre que
j'ai développé une vision totalement
partial des choses que j'examine et
réfléchit surtout à la lueur de la
science il est évident que ma façon de
penser et de raisonner est influencé par
ma formation scientifique qui cela
n'était pas le cas
les études que j'ai suivi aurait été une
perte de temps et un échec mais tu
semble considérer la science ou du moins
c'est ainsi que tu en parles comme une
invention humaine qui peut nuire à la
morale qui est sans rapport avec la vie
réelle
une invention qui doit être
soigneusement écartés de la vie
quotidienne mais la science et la vie
quotidienne ne peuvent et ne doivent pas
être cloisonné
selon moi la science fournit une
explication partielle de la vie comme je
vous le disais en début de vidéo
rosalind franklin figurent parmi les 250
cartes du jeu de société féministe bac
is only à la manière d'un time's
up il consiste à faire deviner un
maximum de cartes à son équipe en demi
moore mots selon les manches et parmi
les femmes citées dans le jeu on y
retrouve autant des scientifiques des
sportives des femmes politiques des
artistes
l'idée est de lutter contre
l'invisibilisation des femmes et de leur
redonner la place qu'elle mérite
on y retrouve autant des figures très
connues comme madonna ou cléopâtre que
des femmes qui ont été oubliés comme moi
francklin pour découvrir qui sont ces
dernières un petit livret le bas de nico
est disponible dans la boîte est décrit
en quelques lignes qui elles sont comme
ça vous pourrez vous améliorez de partie
en partie y vous refaire une culture
féministe pour l'avoir testé avec une
botte est plutôt qu'à les cultures
actuelles musicale et moi plutôt qu'à
les histoires étonnamment c'était très
sympa facile à jouer et on a fait
quelques belles découvertes
vous pouvez commander le jeu sur le site
internet qui s'affiche donc je mettrai
aussi le lien en descriptions merci
d'avoir suivi cet épisode
j'espère qu'il vous a plu et je vous
retrouve la prochaine fois pour un
chronique de profs
[Musique]